well the Prime Minister's also been out
campaigning today talking accusing the
SNP and labour of considering a
so-called toxic alliance after the
general election well let's discuss that
a little bit more with me are two
commentators on the situation here in
Scotland they are rolling mcalpine the
founder of commonweal which some people
believe kicked off the recent boom in
the support for the SNP am Katherine
McLeod former adviser to Alistair
Darling in the better together campaign
welcome to you both and people are
talking about a phenomenon a massive
swing change in public opinion in a
Westminster election what do you think
is happening here in Scotland I think
it's fairly straightforward all across
the UK that is deep cynicism boat
Westminster and the difference in
Scotland is that there's a positive
alternative so people in England I think
what if you feel that lay down with the
big parties if you lay down by
Westminster and there's nowhere where
the greens are strong enough to make
that kind of shift really positive and
the rest of its you kept which there's
not a good option for a lot of people so
what I think you're failing in Scotland
is that we won't end up in politics and
right now there's a vehicle for the S&P
are offering that and people are moving
in droves Catherine universe was very
bitter political loads of them do you
think that's what's happening I think it
is I think that Robin is right i think
that people are very disillusioned with
Westminster that they've never really
known what Scottish own peace have done
at Westminster have been very bad at
selling themselves in the Scottish media
and I think this shift is not certainly
not the media's fault but the shift of
the Scottish media moved to Holyrood
rather than Westminster Tony Blair
gettin in 97 with a huge majority so
there was no sort of fight in
Westminster this legislation was going
through which new kind of on the Lord so
people didn't know that that had been
you know increases in tax credits
increases in Cheryl kid increase in
pieces and Pensions it and it got loud
was largely unreported there was also
another very important thing is that
whenever the Scottish Parliament was
founded that the a lot of politics and
Scotland was seen through the prism of
the Constitution and it ordinary
politics of your light got lost so
ironically that might mean that
national identity as a separate scottish
national identity is not so important in
this movement no it's not I mean one of
the things that she was quite remarkable
that the independence movement was the
number of people involved in it who are
English or we describe themselves as
auntie nationals the green is the Smurfs
you in the Green Party who describe
themselves as nationalists this was
about different politics and a sense
that after 40 years since that should
arrive Westminster never reformed its
sale thing it didn't change and people
just started to look and see what's the
was the vehicle who's going to make this
happen now a lot of people started to
believe that independence was the only
option but now that we're not
independent what they're saying is icky
but we still meant what we said about a
better country a theatre country and
more decent politics and this is the way
that we think we can engage with her
what did labour go wrong because they
were extremely dominant here for a long
period of time after we have a Scottish
UK Prime Minister yeah I think Roberts
wrong I think we're supposed to tune
quite radically I think that people
plants didn't know how much it had
changed I think that it's ludicrous to
see that nationalism must put nothing to
do with it if all these people wanted
the Labour Party to the form they should
have got into the Labour Party and
change the Liberal Party and you know
with the Liberal Party would
enthusiastic and but they accepted
evolution which was delivered by the
labour party and all the other things
we're delivered by the labour party so I
do not know how anybody can see that
nationalism is not one of the dividing
lines between people in the labor party
and people in the Scottish National
Party and the people in the Liberal
Party have worked very hard to make the
world the whole of the United Kingdom
feel him more favorable I mean what
we've got in the moment in the SNP and
everyone is absolutely entitled to vote
smps if they want is that they're
selling the myth of this is a more
left-wing government a fear of
government this is not a progressive
government in Scotland the
redistribution of wealth in Scotland and
the moment is from the poor to the rich
this universal benefits for people go to
university more disadvantaged students
in England go to university land in
Scotland so universal benefits are fine
of a quitter bottomless crush but we
don't have that on either side of the
border and in the UK people are trying
to register it really just runny and
save it as a poet what is
that no no no progressive government
five years of that argument in Labor's
dying in Scotland it so keep saying yes
you guys see it nobody believes it so
well look at the facts and we surely
Williams got a letter than the times to
do seeing that class sizes are getting
bigger not smaller than the NHS and
Scott lenders in difficulties that if
you have kept me counsel and Scotland
every health department is completing
its galette robber puppy I mean is it
perhaps that there's a romance about
this which isn't borne out by the
reality all the politics has never borne
out by its reality politics is always
about more offering more than you ever
actually get and I'm not I'm not
unrealistic about the fact that the SNP
is not some sort of socialist utopia for
bren it's just better than everything
else we've got eight and it's an honest
party that's standing for what it really
believes in it thank you very very much
indeed